Dead arms, dead legs, dead feet!
DEATH IS EVERYWHERE.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey everyone!
Laci Green here for DNews.
You wake up in the morning sleeping on your
arm, and as you go to move: nothin.
Complete deadness.
A dead arm can be such a strange experience
- like you no longer have any control over
it.
I can pick it up with my other hand and wave
it around, which feels tingly and brings the
sensation back slowly.
Sometimes there's even this brief prickly
burning that actually hurts.
I distinctly remember the first time this
happened to me when I was 10 or 11.
For a moment I thought something was seriously
wrong with me.
Like, OH MY GOD I BROKE MY HAND!
But, HERE I AM.
Still alive with hands in tact.
Turns out, dead arms, feet, legs, and other
limbs are a very common occurrence AND it's
pretty interesting why it happens.
In order to have control of your limbs, your
brain needs to be able to communicate through
your nerve pathways to say "MOVE ARM!"
"WALK, LEG!".
Those nerve pathways also carry sensation
information back to your brain that tell you
how something feels or that it's moving.
BUT, when any sort of pressure is applied
to a part of your body for awhile, it squeezes
those nerve pathways and the electrochemical
impulses can't transmit and tell the body
part what to do.
It's a common misunderstanding that you get
a dead limb because blood flow stops - but
if that were true, you could say byebye to
your hand and criss-cross-applesauce? - would
be a deadly undertaking.
What actually happens with the pressure on
the arteries is that it cuts off the nutrient
supply to your NERVE CELLS, making them get
all weird.
The cells might stop transmitting information,
they might start freaking out and sending
impulses ALL OVER THE PLACE.
Those erratic impulses are actually why it
feels like pins and needles, the official
name of which is "paresthesia".
This is what happens when you hit your funny
bone -- or the Ulnar nerve running along your
elbow -- as well.
Cell freakout from the pressure.
As you shake out your dead limb, the nerves
slowly re-establish themselves, and it can
take a sec for the impulses to go back to
normal.
Or sometimes....more then a sec.
I've had it last a minute or two before.
Having your nerves misfire while there's some
pressure on them isn't a huge deal.....unless
it goes on for a long time.
It's actually pretty handy that a lot of the
time a limb will start to tingle first - it's
your body trying to alert you before you do
some serious damage.
With prolonged pressure, the nerves could
stop transmitting feeling all together.
SO!
There you have it.
Now go to a swing at your friend's funny bone
and give them a science lesson.
Or don't actually.
That's kind of evil.
Thanks for watching DNews folks, we'll be
back soon with more science updates!